Now we've done a lot of work. We've learned how to identify the instance
variables of a class, how to provide the methods, how to write the constructors
and the result has been a lot of code. But we've forgotten something very, very
important. How does one use this code and who's one? That would be the
programmer who doesn't want to know what goes on inside the car class but who
just wants to write programs that drive cars around. Now, for a car, when we
have an owner's manual but for code, what you want is Javadoc. Let me show you
what one needs to put into the code to get the javadoc. Over here you see the
same car class that we've been developing. But I've added documentation
comments. These comments are enclosed in these delimiters. You see them over
here. You see another set of over here. And at the top of the class, you see a
class comment that describes the purpose of the class. At the top of every
constructor and of every method, you see a method comment. For every parameter
there is a line explaining what the parameter means. And for those methods that
return a value, there is a comment that explains what the method returns. Now,
previously, you have seen the javadoc comments in a webpage, the way to get
such a webpage for your own classes is to run the javadoc tool, which we can
easily do from within BlueJ. In the main BlueJ menu, pick tools, then project
documentation and you'll get to see a webpage in the familiar javadoc format
that contains exactly the same comments. They were in the source file that's
what javadoc tool does. It takes the comments from the source file and puts
them into the web page. For example, here you see the description of a
parameter and that's the exact same description that was provided in the source
code. Notice that over here this method looks rather naked, no description, no
parameter description, oh, that's because there is no java.com in here. So it's
your turn now. Go ahead and put it in.